how did you learn how to write a
feature-length script yeah I never went
to any master programs I never went to
any film programs that specifically
taught me my craft as I'd mentioned Cu
was more about film theory and various
things like that it didn't really teach
me in great depth what you need to do as
a director or writer I had to learn all
that on my own whether I did it right or
wrong who's to say but for me is that it
looted to you before I just wrote and
wrote and wrote and wrote and through
all that writing through all those years
you start to find your own voice and
when I wasn't writing I was reading
again great scripts different kinds of
scripts the more type of scripts the
better any different styles you know you
never want to get attached to one
person's style that he might start to
emulate it I mean read different styles
and go gosh this is amazing I never
thought you could do it this way and
what I eventually earned learned through
the years is is when I'm writing my
scripts I don't just want to write a
scene or write a story
I bring literally the words the
structure of the sentences themselves to
life I break things apart certain
descriptions certain ways I do it
depending on the project it should be an
experience to read it and it should be
something that literally pulls the
reader from one page to the next where
they can't stop if your script doesn't
hook the reader on the first page you're
done that's just the realities is a lot
of agents and managers will joke well
I'll give you the old five page rule
there was the rule of thumb some say ten
but that means I'll read the first five
pages and if it doesn't have me I don't
read the rest because these guys are
reading hundreds of scripts a week they
don't got time and they've got a good
radar they know it gets it in my
personal opinion I think they give it
half a page or page if your script just
isn't really good both from a
grammatical structural story standpoint
whatever it is immediately you're not
going to gain any traction to them so
that's the goal as a writer as you keep
writing and when I was teaching myself
to write I
aspired to get to that point I want to
pull them in from the first sentence and
never let them go and how to achieve
that in a variety of different genres
and you know whatever your stories about
was a challenge and you just keep
working on it until you get it did you
read any books or screenwriting books or
no it was just all scripts and watch
movies okay yeah yeah and I that's a
good point you just made watch and watch
a lot of movies watch some good movies
you can learn a lot from that what some
people will do because you know writing
is seeming a lot of dialogue can be
tricky because once you film it you go
boy this is so it's just lunch of
Talking Heads this is so dialogue heavy
watch a great scene between two
characters talking in a movie and then
write it down most of the time not all
the time well there in store it might be
a different choice or a different
circumstance but with most writers once
you write down the dialogue some of your
favorite movies you'll see it's a lot
shorter than you think these guys know
what they're doing they know how to
write something that that doesn't turn
into a five page monologue watch a lot
of movies watch them and learn from them
and then again keep reading screeding
lots of different screenplays obviously
I'm sure there's some invaluable books
out there you could read and obviously
there's master programs you can go out
there and get a masters in screenwriting
and for all I know you can write the
pants off of me after going there for a
year but there's certainly those types
of things are available to anyone at any
time I never had the time or money for
it so I did it you could say the hard
way but you know for me it was just I
guess I'd learned through my directing
and producing that experience breeds
experience and that's what pushed me
forward so it was the same with my
writing I wasn't reading books I was
just writing in what reading I was doing
was other people's work what's working
for them what are they doing that I'm
not doing in my scripts and I would
never try to emulate their voice because
every great script writer you can read
it you could almost go I know who wrote
this would never try to emulate that but
I would just from a broad stroke
standpoint look and go what are they
doing that's so great
you know you obviously the best script
screenplays I've ever read as I'm
reading it I visualized the movie I
don't even think about the writing it
just pulls you in to such a degree that
before you know it you've gone through
it and you've been perfectly visualizing
the film and you don't feel yourself
turning the pages you don't feel
yourself reading the paragraphs how do I
get to that point so I would read these
guys and read them and read them and
just try to make my own writing better
and I'm still doing that to this day
always trying to push myself to me
better did you see him is it Nosferatu
Bela Lugosi it was like oh the original
yeah there's no dialogue right oh yeah
oh there is okay no no I'm saying which
I love by the way no dialogue in fact
that was another challenge I gave myself
back when I was doing shorts I did short
with no dialogue can I tell a great
story without a single word I love
things like and in fact one of my
favorite features when I was a kid was I
think was black stallion black stallion
was such a good movie but pretty much
the first half of film is dialogue free
it's a boy and it's in the horse
on an island right and it's fabulous
it's so good and there's not a word you
know or if there are it's just a couple
here and there that's still something
I'm mastering when it comes to writing
because you know as the general rule of
thumb is it's a minute per page when
you're writing you write a page of you
one page of your script equals about a
minute of screen time by and large I
guess that's true but I mean if you
don't have dialogue it really can alter
things and I ran into challenges with
that with escape room because there was
certain segments that were dialogue free
a lot of action happening in inside of
this escape room and when we got to
actually shooting and I went this is
gonna be a lot shorter than I had
originally planned you know I don't want
to have like the nicest like 50 minute
feature ever so I had to kind of work my
way around that and kind of find some
other ways to tell the story but you
know I'm a big fan of that I did you
know sriracha was something you I think
I watched the first part of it and it
was just very slow and I just found a
very interesting because it was creepy
and it was scary yeah but but just yeah
the the the slow the pacing of it and
yeah it's not everyone's cup of tea sure
you know listen it sometimes the slow
burn is a little bit too slow there's
another old film by I think it was Carl
Theodor Dreyer around the same time as
Nosferatu I believe 1932 1919 31 is
called the vampyre that one you should
check out same thing all that was fear
amazing experimental photography of
these kind of foreboding shadow figures
right yeah didn't have special effects
it was all practical but it was very
clever and it was just a very different
take the Nosferatu but very interesting
not everyone's cup of tea I showed it to
a group of friends once and they all
split it was me watching the phone but
but it still a worthy experience at the
other time
you